support for big thing comes from
Microsoft delivering people ready
enterprise solutions designed to help
companies do more with less details at
microsoft com / people ready
I'm Alice Rivlin and I'm a senior fellow
at the Brookings Institution
there are some quite obvious things that
companies can do right now depending on
what kind of companies they are if we're
fixing our crumbling infrastructure than
companies that specialize in doing that
will benefit if we're giving more people
access to broadband that is certainly an
opportunity if we're making our
healthcare system more efficient there
will be some people who will lose by
that but there will also be both
providers and the healthcare technology
industry that will benefit
the stimulus plan is I think widely
misunderstood because people think of it
as just infrastructure it is partly that
but the most important part of the
stimulus I thought were the parts that
got money to individuals so that they
could keep paying their bills that means
the Food Stamp part the unemployment
benefits increase the modest increase in
Social Security benefits and the other
part that seemed to me very important
where the benefits to States to keep
them from cutting back on their services
so and I didn't even mention the the tax
cuts which go to ordinary people those
things will keep a demand up it will
keep consumption up and it'll benefit
businesses across the board there's no
special benefit here it just means that
people will not be cutting back on their
consumption as much as they ordinarily
would have
we were bringing a lot of talent to Wall
Street that in my opinion would have
been better employed doing something
else the financial services industry got
way out of kilter with the rest of the
economy financial services are supposed
to be serving the rest of the economy
actually our financial services industry
got into a position where it was largely
servicing itself we don't need that many
smart people inventing more and more
complex derivatives and instruments to
sell to each other there is very little
social benefit in that activity now I
don't mean we can close down all
derivatives markets or anything like
that but if compensation in financial
services is less astronomical and we
attract less of our high high skilled
talent into financial services and more
of it into other parts of the economy
it'll be all to the good
this massive disaster has certainly
exposed weaknesses in the financial
sector some we knew were there many we
didn't and we need a drastic overhaul I
think on two fronts partly it is a
question of modernizing our regulatory
system which simply did not keep up with
the advances in financial innovation and
globalization that were happening all
around us that means stricter regulation
for major institutions that are very
interlinked with the rest of the economy
and indeed with the global economy they
can't be too strict we need those major
institutions the second front which i
think is more important is we need to go
over our economic structure our economic
architecture and look for perverse
incentives places where there are
incentives that mean that people can
make a lot of money doing something
really risky now we had a good example
of that in mortgage lending the mortgage
lending standards got very relaxed in
part because we missed a perverse
incentive we missed the fact that the
loan originator has no reason to worry
about the creditworthiness of the
borrower if he doesn't keep any of that
risk himself if he's just selling this
mortgage to somebody else as part of a
package backing a bond issue then he has
no reason to worry about whether the
borrower can repay that was a perverse
incentive it had been there for a while
but nobody noticed it it was the big
influx of capital into the
mortgage-backed security market a lot of
it coming from overseas that expose this
weakness and we have to look for things
like that and
change them
I think that President Obama has to work
right now on the thing that is most
important namely getting out of this
recession and getting the financial
services industry functioning again if
he doesn't accomplish that and I think
he will it will be a disaster for
business we need a functioning economy
where people have jobs we need to be a
more sustainable economy than we were
before both in an environmental sense
and in the sense that we need to save
more and finance more of our own
investment out of domestic saving I
think that will happen because people
who borrowed too much and consumed too
much got badly burned but we need an
economy which is functioning well and in
which people are saving more borrowing
less and doing more productive work
support for big thing comes from
Microsoft delivering people ready
enterprise solutions designed to help
companies do more with less details at
microsoft com / people ready